ami wrote in saying what's something you
would like to become better at okay well
piggybacking on our last conversation I
have always been terrible at visual arts
like I can't draw and I'm terrible at
painting so I recently actually have
committed to becoming better at this
I bought a pencil kit as well as some
sketch pads and a book called like you
know learn how to draw in 30 days and
I'm taking longer than 30 days because
I'm only doing the exercises every few
days but I am trying to just get some
basic drawing skills just so when
somebody says oh can you sketch what you
have in mind for I don't know you know
like a house design or some or what the
studio should look like I can actually
maybe make something that's not
embarrassingly bad so I would really
like to be better at stuff like that
well I loved your first work of art what
was it smiley faced clouds and we even
covered it on an Instagram Eggman that
was quite that wasn't my first that was
the first you were around for but I did
one a couple years ago that somebody
called I think asparagus sunrise or
something like that because the trees in
the picture and the in the painting
looks like asparagus or something like
that so I have a long history of a bad
painting I'm sure the painting looked
like a pac-man you know identified that
looks like a van Gogh yours yeah yeah
there's no mistaking it that's for damn
sure
no but I would I would say generally
visual arts and you know off and on I I
do I try to learn computer programming
web programming so that I could just be
better I have a general sense of PHP and
HTML and a little bit of JavaScript only
enough to be able to recognize what I'm
looking at but not really be effective
as a programmer I guess that would be
what's on my list interesting yeah I
would like to get better at music
because I've played guitar for quite a
few years yeah but I've plateaued
because I've gotten to a point where you
know I can strum chords and sing songs
at a campfire yeah and that's all I
really set out to do I'm not really
getting into any intricate scales or
anything else and it's one of those
things that you have to really practice
every single day to improve with and
because I'm going in and out of it with
phases I'm not really seeing the same
trajectory as I was in the first couple
years you should pick up I mean
obviously lessons would be the best but
for ten bucks you could pick up some
pretty good guitar instruction books
that you just sit down
and just learn the scales and then and
the thing
pickings that are on there you would
probably improve dramatically yeah the
problem is a lot of these exercises you
have to do where you learn the scales
and maybe intricate chords are just kind
of boring yeah so I wouldn't commit to
doing it unless perhaps maybe I was
paying someone and going to lessons
every single year because even though
you can find all that information online
nowadays it's just nice to have someone
to be accountable to each week what
about picking songs that instead of
chords you would play the melody on so
they'd be song as you like so that would
be might be more more fun to learn but
then I can't use the voice you know it's
all about the voice with that's true
yeah someday we are going to play Pat
singing on the show and I think people
will be big ly impressed by it